the work of Bernard Fung in my lab told
us
that a crucial player
in visual transduction
was
a guanineucleotide binding protein and
so
we then
set out
to purify the protein
Bernard
very good at this
and in short order
Found A protein that had three subunits
alpha beta and gamma
and that this was indeed the guandial
nucleotide binding protein
it's what we call today translucent
because it plays a key role in the
transduction process
so having this
protein
enabled us
to create to
plan a series of experiments
to see whether it played a key role in
vision
our hypothesis was that the flow of
information
is from photo excited rhodopsin
to
the squandial nucleotide binding protein
now known as transducin
to the phosphodiesterase
and so
it's a very
precise prediction
and it makes
two
sub predictions
the first is
that photo excited rhodopsin should be
able
to catalyze
to trigger
the activation of transducin
in the absence of the phosphodiesterase
and the second prediction
is that translucent
should be able when it's in the GTP form
should be able
to activate
the phosphodiesterase
in the absence of photoexcited rhodopsin
Bernard Fung was joined by Jim Hurley
another very talented postdoctoral
fellow and they worked very closely
together
and
they tested the first prediction
can photoexcited rudopsin trigger GTP
GDP Exchange in transducin without the
phosphodiesterase being around
and so what was prepared were
reconstituted membranes
that had only the phospholipid of the
membrane
they had rhodopsin
and translucent was added
and so here we have
membranes phospholipid membranes
containing rhodopsin
we add translucent
we shine light in a controlled way
and what we found was in fact
GTP went in
GDP came out we observed that a single
photo excited rhodopsin LED to The
Exchange
of 71 molecules of GTP for GDP so the
first part of our proposed flow of
information
was tested in this experiment and
validated
now we then wanted to see
whether transducin in the GTP state
could activate the phosphodiesterase
with no
in in the dark with no photo excited
rhodopsin present
and
so
the first step was to purify
transducin bearing the non-hydrolyzable
analog of GTP so that we could keep it
in the GTP state
and we encountered a very pleasant
surprise during the purification process
instead of seeing the radioactivity come
out with the three subunits altogether
alpha beta and gamma of transducin
altogether
what we found was that having transducin
in the GTP state
in the presumably active state
led to the dissociation
of the alpha subunit of transducin from
beta and gamma
so we were able
to
pose a more precise question than we had
originally planned
namely
is it the alpha subunitor of transducin
with its bound GTP analog
uh
can that complex
activate the phosphodie historase
and we were so excited and thrilled to
find that the alpha subunit bearing the
GTP analog
led to the full activation of the
phosphodiesterase
you know this was one of the wonderful
moments you you know
it works beautifully you've suddenly
seen how a piece of nature works it
happens so rarely in science and it's a
truly a moment to treasure and I I don't
think we pulled out the champagne but we
were certainly uh very very happy when
we found that the information carrying
intermediate is the alpha subunit of
transducin bearing GTP I think of the uh
very lovely
writing of William Rushton an English
physiologist who worked on vision
he said molecules respond to light as do
people to music
some absorb nothing
some respond by the degraded vibration
of foot or finger
but some there are who rise and dance
and change partners and so suddenly
we saw the molecular choreography we saw
what photo excited rhodopsin interacting
with transducens sending the alpha
subunit onto the phosphodiesterase and
suddenly you know the molecular ballet
of vision opened up to us and and that
was a thrilling moment a great moment